what is going on everybody welcome to
another Raspberry Pi tutorial in this
tutorial we're going to be covering how
to remote access the desktop so you
won't have to have a dedicated monitor
yet you're not required to use something
like SSH if you're not yet comfortable
with it I will just say like a lot of
things with this Raspberry Pi of it this
is kind of like a transition into
getting used to using a lot of these
tools instead so this is kind of a way
to remote access yet not really have a
monitor and all that but eventually you
should really learn SSH and how to you
know use SSH it's a good skill to have
if you ever plan on having like running
a website on like a VPS or some sort of
web server it's just it's just a good
idea to get used to and comfortable with
using SSH but for now that that's
probably for a later tutorial we did
cover some of the stuff I believe in
earlier tutorials but maybe eventually
I'll do like a full SSH tutorial
especially that connecting to your pot
so with that and probably it'll go along
with the web server tutorial I'll
probably expand on those eventually
however this tutorial probably the last
software-only tutorial with the PI for
at least a little bit I'm going to be
getting into the hardware and
electronics stuff in the next few
tutorials
you know the PI can act like a server
and all this kind of fun stuff and you
can do some cool software stuff but
really what gets even more cool is the
electronics and hardware portion of it
and I believe that's one of the reasons
the makers of Pi made pies you know get
people excited and interested in the
electronics aspect also another
interesting thing that I'll probably do
once I get a little bit more money and
can buy a few more pies is you can learn
a lot about super computing and
networking with the Raspberry Pi and
it's a lot cheaper than the normal route
which is to buy a bunch of computers so
pretty cool stuff in the future the
Raspberry Pi
pretty awesome machine but for now let's
talk up about remote desktop another
reason you might want to be your do
remote desktop is in case you want to be
one of those cool cats that does
Raspberry Pi tutorials this is a good
way to do it you remote desktop in it
and then you can use your desk your main
computer screen recorder and record the
screen and you can you know get a decent
frames per second out of it and all that
so with that let's go ahead and hop
right on in to get but we're gonna use X
the RP the reason we're going to use
this is it's cutter I'm sorry it's xrdp
the reason we're going to use this is
pretty lightweight remote connection
right there is you could get the source
for TeamViewer probably and put team
gear up here but it's that would just I
mean the resources the TeamViewer case
is pretty high so anyway we're going to
use this and besides you know we're just
we're making a land connection so we
don't really need a whole lot of power
to transfer so open up your terminal
longest intro ever by the way
so epic terminal and let me go ahead and
make this slightly bigger so everybody
can see it
mono space remember what I used to do I
think was 16:9 we were big boys 16 okay
that's good enough so now if to actually
get xrdp what you're gonna want to type
in is sudo apt-get install xrdp now and
then hit enter now I've already
installed it so it's gonna be like huh
idiot you actually have this app to get
no good anyway it's gonna tell me that I
already have it but for you it should
actually install it for you so yes I
already have it and it's the newest
version so anyway but for you you should
be running through it and install at the
moment so while it's installing
I guess pause the video because now I'm
gonna showing you the next few steps so
pause it and whenever it's done
installing
all righty welcome back hopefully you
got your stuff installed now the next
thing we want to do is get our local IP
address because that's what we're going
to use to connect so to do that you just
need it's kind of like IP config from a
Windows machine and but here it is I
those type in here if' config so not IP
can be a guy ifconfig someone knows why
it's if I have to thing feel free to
post it below I'm kind of curious so
anyway you'll hit enter and you'll get
all your IP addresses you'll get your
broadcast your mask and finally right
here is where what you're gonna be
mainly looking for and that is your
local IP address so now that we see that
it is a 12 for me since it's my 12th
computer continuing on once you have
that information the next thing we want
to do is on your Windows machine and you
have remote desktop so go over here and
you want to type in just type in remote
that'll probably take you there and
right here you've got remote desktop
connection so go ahead and hit that here
we go I've already done it a few times
I'm connected at the moment so my IP is
already in there but yeah you'll just
take that local IP right there slap it
on in there and if you want the other
thing you can do sometimes like the
display is a little Funkadelic and so
the way to get around that is go to your
options display and you can choose like
what display you want to have I believe
it comes normally like at least when I
did it my display was massive it was
bigger than my it was bigger than 1920
by 1080 like I have a 1920 by 1080
monitor and when I connected it was like
it was just huge so anyway just keep
that in mind the other thing I'll just
mention is the way it works even though
you're logging like when you hit connect
it's going to ask you for your login
information and so that's gonna be your
your login information for your your PI
so if you haven't changed your password
that means username is PI password is
raspberry however if you've change
your password like we did we changed our
password in the the webserver tutorials
so if you followed that web server
tutorial and did change your password
you know whatever your password was put
that in there and then you'll connect
and it'll take you right here so the
next thing I just want to mention is if
you the way it works even though yeah
you've got like a user account and like
if you're from a Windows machine when
you log in to your user account when you
log in to your user account right so
everything you do is someone else was on
that user account well it just wouldn't
even happen and feel like this user has
already logged in but you're in theory
if you remote desktop your own Windows
machine you would be sharing that
desktop so if you move the mouse on one
computer move the mouse on the other
computer it's not the case on a Linux
system so for example what I'm going to
do is to show you like down here this is
your process monitor as you can see
we're we're not doing anything so it's
it's well relatively low and stable but
let me show you I'm gonna go to my main
cuz I do have a dedicated monitor for my
PI so I'm gonna come over here and I'm
gonna open up some stuff on my PI and
you should see the problem just like
clicking around on the desktop and you
can already see the process is going up
but anyway you should see it you know
skyrocket like it normally does so I
opened up a few idols and so as you can
see we didn't do anything over here but
yet the process is for this specific you
know one went up and you didn't see me
doing anything right like we're not
actually opening anything and you might
be like hi you're an idiot because this
has like two desktops right because you
can look here like this is your main
desktop you can switch to desktop too so
to speak it's still not here right I
have three idols open but we're not
seeing them so anyway just kind of an
aside like you can't share the desktop
with this there might be a way you can
do it I just don't know it so anyway
that's gonna conclude
the sharing or the remote desktops just
got done saying we can't show the
desktop anyway that's gonna conclude the
remote desktop tutorial stay tuned for
my hardware in electronics tutorials
I've been pretty busy lately but I'm
pretty excited to put those out it's
a lot of fun stuff maybe eventually I
see a lot of tutorials on or not
tutorials I see a lot of videos on
YouTube people building like robots and
stuff with the Raspberry Pi but they're
not you know they don't tell you like
how they did it they just show you it
like hey cool check this out and nobody
actually has like a tutorial on how to
do it
probably because it's a whole lot of
information so maybe that's why but I
might try and tackle that so anyway as
always thank you for watching thanks for
your support your subscriptions and
until next time